today we're talking about 5g bioshield
which is a website that recently popped
up
that calls itself the first to market
full spectrum protection now this thing
only has 128 megabytes in the usb
comes in at a price of 283 pounds or
roughly 300
if you want to buy it which makes it the
world's most expensive usb
per the amount of storage you get but
that's not really why people are buying
it and people are snatching this thing
up left and right if you go to their
testimonial page they already have quite
a few testimonials the real reason
people are buying it is because they
claim to prevent
5g from touching you using
force field technology i mean let's read
it
it uses a nano layer quantum holographic
catalyzer technology
for the balance and harmonization of the
harmful effects
of imbalanced electric radiation the
nano layer
operating diameter is either 4 8 to 40
meters
now that seems like a big difference and
that's why they show the
the small personal force field or the
big
force field for your house and what they
say the difference is if you plug in the
usb or not
apparently this is a technology so
advanced um
you know you don't even need it to be
plugged in
it's working even if you're it's not
plugged in so if you're just carrying it
in your pocket you're protected
from 5g but then if you actually plug it
in you're even more protected from 5g
can you believe it
now the reason this is the news is that
this website pin test partners
took the usb apart and found out that
hey
surprise surprise it's just a regular
128 megabyte usb
key it doesn't actually create magical
force fields and of course in response
to the serious allegations made against
them
the 5g bioshock company said you know
they want to release the information
that shows how this thing works
they want to release a great deal of
technical information with plenty of
backup historical research but
unfortunately for all of us they're
unable to disclose this sensitive
information to third parties
you know they want to they want to tell
you how it works seriously they do
they're dying to tell you how it works
but they
can't because you know it's it's ip
baby it's ip and i mean yes you can find
the same usb stick
online in aliexpress for two to five
dollars
but you know what what's the point of
that because it doesn't have the nano
crystallography layered technology how's
it going to create a force field without
that
all in all guys i mean i just don't see
it people are calling these grifters
i don't see it i mean look they're
putting proprietary holographic nanotech
layer technology on it i don't
understand how this is a scam at all
you know and if it doesn't work for you
just remember what they say on their
website
you know some users immediately feel the
effects in the form of calm
harmony and serenity but other users
those of us who have been more exposed
to the 5g
more physically impaired we'll have to
wait several days or even weeks
for the body's revitalization mechanisms
to be fully effective
therefore patience and perseverance are
recommended to everyone in order to
benefit maximally from the multiple
effects generated by the 5g
bioshield you know what i think that the
300
price point is definitely obviously
justified
the amount of technology that went into
designing the sticker
that they attach to this 5g usb stick
you know they may get it for five
dollars on
on aliexpress but the the sticker boys
this the nano layer
holographic technology sticker
it's worth every penny that's not to say
that nobody's scamming you though
because i want to show you
today who you really need to watch out
for is this is the
uh look there's 5g bioshield but there's
also these competitors who are trying to
rip them off
this is a competitor the reso tone
shield does not it does not work scam
scam alert now the 5g bioshield
works i mean look just look at their
logos
lion polar bear really do you trust a
polar bear over a lot
these guys are really these are the
scammers legit
obviously scammers look at that usb key
clearly of
inferior quality not a 5g
shield 5g shield of course obvious i
mean look
look look at this product trustworthy
product that's smoke
trustworthy scam trustworthy
scam i mean look they even copied their
logo i'm sickened by this
who would do such a thing whatever you
guys do
don't buy from the polar bear and as
always don't forget to smash like
and subscribe thank you
[Music]
uh
comes along